Our daughter entered her
life at 24 due to depression.
If someone is determined
to end their life,
how can one change their mind?
Oh,
well,
first of all,
I'm very sorry about that.
That's a terrible thing.
Look,
I had this friend
her,
sorry.
There's been a lot of
depression in our family,
so it's a question that
cuts close to the bone.
Anyways,
I had this friend and friend of my
parents and her grand daughter committed
suicide.
You know,
she was just beating herself up
about what could have I done,
what could have I done differently?
This is the problem with suicide.
It leaves everybody behind thinking,
Oh my God,
what could've I done?
I could have treated the person better.
I could have listened.
I could have been there.
It's like,
and she was just beating yourself up about
this really feeling that she wasn't a
useful person,
that she'd failed as a grandmother.
She's a really good person,
you know?
And so I went for a walk
with her and I said,
and she,
she's married and she likes her husband,
and he's a really good guy.
I met.
He said,
look,
you're,
you're blaming yourself for the,
for your granddaughter,
suicide.
It's like,
are you blaming your husband?
Are you sitting him down
and telling him what to use?
Useless bastard.
He was as a grandfather because his grand
daughter committed suicide and how he
failed completely.
She said,
no,
I'd never do that.
So I said,
well,
don't do it to yourself.
No people.
Depression was a terrible thing and many,
many,
many things cause it,
and we don't understand.
We understand some of them,
but lots of them we
don't understand at all.
You know,
sometimes people get depressed
because they're really sick.
We know that depression could
be an inflammatory disease,
it might be associated with audio,
immune dysfunction.
There's lots of reasons that
people get depressed and depressed.
People can go places that are so dark,
you just cannot imagine it.
And it isn't necessarily the case
that you can always rescue someone,
you know,
and,
but,
but drowning yourself in the
aftermath of a suicide is not helpful.
So there's a,
there's a good room for
self forgiveness there.
You know,
I mean,
maybe you did some things you shouldn't
have done that were reprehensible and
all of that,
but you don't want to beat yourself up.
Remember the presumption of innocence,
right?
Innocent until proven guilty and
you have to apply that to yourself.
I don't think.
I think there are times when people are
so depressed or if there isn't anything
that anyone can do.
You know when the depressed person thinks,
and this is probably the worst part of it,
it depressed person thinks
everywhere I look,
it's nothing but catastrophe and there's,
I can't see any way out of it.
I,
I can't see any path forward
whatsoever and then they think as well,
and maybe it's the combination of these
two thoughts that that really make
people suicidal.
It's like it's hopeless.
It isn't going to get any better.
No matter where I turn,
there's no escape.
The suffering is unbearable and I
had absolutely no use whatsoever.
Do anyone.
It would be better for everyone if
I was just gone because I'm going,
if I'm not so much of a burden now
that it's going to destroy their life,
then I'm going to be that much
of a burden in the future.
And so target,
imagine what that's like for people,
but it's dreadful and there's
lots of ways you get there and so
you can listen to people.
You can desperately encouraged
them to seek the help they need.
You know,
like I've,
I've seen antidepressants
work miracles on very,
very many people now.
They don't work for everyone
and they're not a panacea,
but you know,
they have side effects and all of that.
But one of the side effects of untreated
depression is that you kill yourself
and there is no recovery from that.
And the are the probabilities
actually rather high.
So you can go to war with
them about antidepressants.
If the person can't get out
of their depression and their,
and their suicidal,
it's like what do they have to
lose one month on antidepressants?
They'll know,
oh,
they might have to experiment
longer because it would depend on,
you know,
some people respond better to some classes
of antidepressants than the others.
Um,
it's worth having a war with someone if
they're in dire straits and they won't
do everything they can to get better.
ECT works.
Electric convulsive therapy
works for intractable depression.
It's a terrible thing to contemplate,
but the modern versions of ECT aren't
one flew over the cuckoo's nest.
And again,
it's like there's no
coming back from death.
So look,
it isn't clear.
You can't rescue everyone.
People get sick and they die.
And sometimes the way they die,
it looks like it's depression.
Depression is a multifaceted phenomena.
You can be there for them,
you can listen,
you can watch,
you can intervene,
you can try to understand,
you can hold them accountable.
You can do all of those things,
but that,
but everyone has their own destiny,
you know,
and you're not omnipotent.
And so sometimes it catastrophe
yield curves like your daughters and
then,
and then you should try to drag the least
amount of misery forward that you can.
Okay.
Once you recover from your grief.
Yup.